Good day, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn, from the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center, located at the University
of Southern California.
And I'd like to welcome you all to our next
installment of the Big Data to Knowledge Guide
to the Fundamentals of Data Science.
And today, we're in Section 4.
And we're absolutely delighted to have Pavel
Pevzner from the University of California,
San Diego, presenting to us today on Algorithms
& Optimization.
And Dr. Pevzner is a professor of computer
science and engineering and the director of
the NIH National Center for Computational
Mass Spectrometry, at the University of California
in San Diego.
He earned his PhD from the Moscow Institute
of Physics and technology in Russia and was
elected as an ACM fellow in 2010 for his contributions
to algorithms for genome re-arrangement, DNA
sequencing in proteomics.
He's also a International Society for Computational
Biology fellow, as well as has earned honors
from the European Academy of Sciences, in
2016; an honorary doctorate from the Simon
Fraser University, in Vancouver, Canada; and
has authored several works with his colleague
Phillip Compeau, including textbooks on computational
molecular biology and algorithmic approach;
Introduction to Bioinformatics Algorithms,
and Bioinformatics Algorithms [? in ?] Active
Learning Approach.
And in 2013, he developed a very popular bioinformatics
specialization on the Coursera online course
series, which was his own.
It was a series of seven different courses
and it has already had over 300,000 enrollments.
And in 2006, also jointly with Phillip Compeau,
he developed a biology meets programming online
course in Coursera that introduces biologists
to some programming methodologies.
And so without further ado, I'd like to welcome
Dr. Pevzner.
And we're absolutely delighted to have him
and to hear what he has to tell us on algorithms
and optimization.
Pavel, the stage is yours.
Thank you, John, for a kind introduction.
And good morning, everybody.
I was asked to talk on [? algorithms ?] in
data science to people who probably never
took an introductory algorithmic course and
who probably do not necessarily know how to
[INAUDIBLE].
It's a tall order, but I will try.
And I want to focus in my talk on this intersection
of two worlds.
One world is a world of biology, where problems
are somewhat imprecisely formulated; and the
world of [? algorithms ?] when w you absolutely
need to be precise in everything that you
are doing.
And I want to describe this breach with an
[INAUDIBLE] researcher and computational researcher.
When it comes to problem formulation, when
a problem moves from biological world to algorithmic
world, what is happening?
In fact, many people underestimate the complexity
of this task.
It takes enormous amount of time for a professional
bioinformatician to transform a problem from
imprecise biological formulation into an algorithmic
problem.
Let's start.
Let's start from something that has little
to do with this biology-- the Newspaper Problem.
Imagine that you have 100s of identical copies
of New York Times.
And you stack it on a pile of dynamite, and
you light the fuse.
Of course, don't do it at home.
And then there is an explosion.
And after this explosion, many pieces are
burned, but something is left.
And your goal is to reconstruct the original
New York Times newspaper.
So what would you do?
Well, you would look at tiny pieces and treat
them as a giant, overlapping puzzle.
For example, when you look at these two pieces,
well, probably they come from the same place.
And you can start assembling them together.
And slowly but surely, the hope is that we
will eventually assemble the volumes.
And you already have figured out that I am
actually talking about genome assembly in
disguise.
And my goal would be to assemble the New York
Times front page [INAUDIBLE] a sequence in
[INAUDIBLE] draft human genome, 17 years ago.
And since that time, there was enormous acceleration
in genomic sequencing.
And currently, there are only, if you took
a bacterial world, there are over 100,000
different bacteria sequence.
And there are also huge efforts on sequencing
individual human genomes, of course.
And our newspaper problem, obviously, it translated
in a biological problem, where instead of
New York Times, we have multiplied [? carcass
?] of a journal.
And we break [? general ?] trend and position.
We generate reads.
And of course, some, not all, reads from all
positions of the genome are present.
And as a result, we have this huge collection
of reads.
And for every read, we have no clue what position
in [? the journal ?] it come from.
Our goal, nevertheless, is to assemble these
pieces into a genome.
And we start looking for overlap exactly like
in the newspaper problem.
Look, we just found an overlap of two pieces.
Maybe we can glue them together and continue
in this way.
That sounds simple.
The only problem is that we have millions
or, in the case of human genome, billions
of such pieces.
And any reasonable algorithm that you use
to assemble a jigsaw puzzle, even if you are
an expert in assembling, let's say, sounds
and business [? pauses, ?] we'll fail, even
with the most powerful computer in the world.
What will you do?
So once again, our setup, we have experimental
challenge.
But we solve it.
We generate its reads.
And finally, we need to assemble it.
How would we formulate this assembly problem?
And I want you to meet these people who seemingly
have nothing to do with more than biology.
At least, Euler and Hamilton have nothing
to do, because [? they were ?] born well before
modern biology was developed.
But without them, we wouldn't be able to sequence
genomes.
They came up with these fundamental mathematical
and algorithmic ideas that actually enable
genome sequencing today.
And I will try to explain how their ideas
propagated into modern biology.
As a result, in fact, today, many biologists,
for example, knows the term [INAUDIBLE].
And currently, many biologists are working
[INAUDIBLE] this so-called reference genomes.
In the future, the reference genomes, probably
they'll become an obsolete notion, because
they need to grow [INAUDIBLE] multiply genomes.
And human genomes are very different.
And they need to somehow represent this variety
of genome as something that people know, called
population graph,or population genome.
And this graph will be represented and is
currently represented based on the idea developed
by De Bruijn, and going back, actually, to
Euler and Hamilton.
So let's see how would we solve the String
Reconstruction Problem.
And in our case, in the genome sequencing
problem setup, we need first to rigorously
formulate our [INAUDIBLE] problem.
That's what I've done.
Our goal is to reconstruct the genome from
reads input to this problem, a collection
of strings that we call reads.
And output is a string genome reconstructed
from reads.
Does it make sense?
Does it look like a rigorous statement that
you can pass to your algorithmic [? conic?
?] And this person will solve the problem.
This seemingly looking reasonable [INAUDIBLE]
formulation is absolutely wrong.
This is not a computational problem.
But many biologists, in faced with a problem
like this, would view it as something that
represent their challenges.
And maybe if [? exactly ?] in this way, if
they would work with algorithmic [? conics,
?] they would represent their problem exactly
like I've done, without understanding that
it is not a computational problem that your
[? conic ?] [INAUDIBLE].
Let me explain why it is not a computational
problem.
Sometime ago, genius mathematician Georg Cantor
said, "To ask the right question is harder
than to answer it."
And so the question above on this slide is
not the right question to ask.
And when we think about problem formulation
and biological scientists, it's good to think
about this as a [INAUDIBLE] context.
Imagine that you want to solve your biological
problems that require computation tools.
But imagine that you never took [? algorithms
?] 101 class.
And imagine that you don't even know how to
[INAUDIBLE].
Not to worry, you can enter into a million
dollar contract which this brilliant computer
scientist, Alice, to solve the genome sequencing
problem.
But keep in mind that Alice lives in a bunker.
And the only way you can communicate with
Alice is by passing her a single page.
What is your problem formulation?
Our problem formulation on the previous slide
definitely fit on a single page.
So this will be satisfied.
This requirement will be satisfied.
Now, however, there are important rules for
communicating with Alice.
You should avoid biological terms.
Alice is very busy, and you are not her only
client.
She has no ability to ask you any question
or to know anything new about genomes.
She only knows computer science.
As long as you formulate the problem, you
can be guaranteed she will solve it.
But you need to formulate it correctly.
If you pass Alice a page with terms like PCR,
she will fall
asleep.
She doesn't understand.
Now, the next bearing point on [INAUDIBLE],
your problem may have [? multiplied ?] algorithmically
correct, but biologically useless solutions.
And Alice actually is free to report any of
them, according to the contract.
She would prefer to report an easy-to-find
solution, because she's busy, and collect
your million dollar payment.
It is important that you problem is formulated
in such a way that any solution written by
Alice will answer the question you are really
interested in.
It is not uncommon, when people formulate
problems, that allow to give useless, still
formally-correct solutions.
Another important thing, make sure that you
can check that Alice's solution is correct.
A well-formulated problem specifies how to
determine whether the output is correct given
the input.
If it does not, can you even check that Alice's
solution is correct?
In The problems that I formulated, this condition
was violated.
And as a result, it did not represent a good
computational problem.
And of course, it is to say you have to be
specific, precise, short, elegant.
Now, with this in mind, let's move toward
a good algorithmic problem formulation for
genome assembly.
We will introduce the concept of k-mer composition.
Given the genome k-mer composition, and k-mer
is simply a continuous substring of a genome
of [? lens ?] k.
So [? 3-mer ?] composition will be simply
a collection of all [? 3mers ?] from the string.
I'll take a liberty to represent it on a single
line.
But the way I represent it here is a little
bit of chicken, because it assumes that I
know the order of this k-mer in my genome.
In reality, I don't know the order of the
k-mers.
And that's why I will represent them in lexicographic
order, in the same way people represent information
in a telephone book.
So it's starting from all strings, starting
from A, and continuing [INAUDIBLE].
And then my string reconstruction problem
will be reconstruct a string from its k-mer
composition.
Input is a collection of k-mers-- it means
your reads-- and output a genome, such that
its composition is equal to the collection
of k-mers or your input trait.
Of course, people working in assembly would
understand that it's a gross oversimplification
of reality.
But let's start from this, and then later,
we will move to a more adequate biological
problem formulation.
It's actually a very common approach in data
science to start from simplifying a problem
to develop main ideas based on simplified
problem formulation and later move to problems
that back a model biological reality.
Now, we now have the problem formulation.
Let's start solving the problem.
Let's [? then ?] assume that I know which
particular [? 3-mer ?] represents a [INAUDIBLE]
Then if it is TAA is the first one, then the
next one should start from AA, right?
So let's bring the next one.
And we're starting assembling.
So we bring the next one.
So here it is.
Then bring the next one.
it is.
But now we have three k-mers, starting from
TG.
Not a problem, so simply, we have multiplied
choices.
Let's select one of them.
Here it is.
Let's continue further.
GT, we need GT.
And then at the next step, we need to find
something starting from TT.
But look.
We don't have any reads starting from TT,
which means that we failed.
So we need to develop something that is a
better way of solving this assembly problem.
So let me describe how biologists have been
solving this problem for a long time.
In fact, I'm describing an approach that was
used for assembling the human genome.
Let's represent every k-mer as a node.
And let's connect nodes corresponding to the
genome by arrows.
I call this arrows.
[? Algorithmists ?] call these arrows [? edges.
?] And as a result, the sequence of this node
will basically read the genome.
But how do they know?
So we've done a little bit of chicken, because
we constructed this graph, assuming we know
the genome.
But can we construct this genome path from
the first node to the last node without knowing
the genome, only from its composition?
At first glance, it looks scarce.
We simply need to connect k-mer 1 with k-mer
2, if suffix of the first k-mer equal to the
prefix of the second k-mer, like shown here.
And in this case, they will construct exactly
the same path, right?
So that's what I've done.
But if you follow these rules that are outlined
at the bottom of this slide, then you have
an obligation to connect every two k-mers
such that suffix of the first one equal to
the prefix of the second one, which means
that you have to connect AAT with ATG.
And you have to connect AAT with [INAUDIBLE],
then continue in this way.
This is all the connections that you have
to make.
And that's why the problem becomes more complex.
And can we still find the genome path in this
graph?
Of course.
It's still this horizontal path.
But we forgot that we do not know the order
[? of ?] correct number of nodes in this graph.
And if [? we ?] order nodes on this graph
in the same way as we do in the phone book,
then the graph looks like this.
It looks like a very complex maze.
And it's absolutely not clear how would we
assemble genomes from this graph.
But clearly, we need to travel in this graph,
starting [? again ?] with TAA, continuing
further.
Continuing further, please note that there
are multiplied choices [? at ?] many steps.
So we continue, continue, continue, continue.
And well, what are we trying to do?
So that, given the graph, which is basically
a latch networks, [? obvious, ?] in the case
of genome assembly problems, this network
will consist of a million cities, representative
nodes, and millions of roads, represented
by [? x's.
?]
And what they're trying to do, they're trying
to visit every node in the graph, right?
Because they need to explain all reads.
Every node explains one of the reads.
So we continue.
And in fact, the problem we are trying to
solve is finding the [? paths.
?] It means that each node in the graph exactly
wants to explain its read.
And this problem is known as a Hamiltonian
Path Problem in computer science.
Input to the problem is a graph.
And output is a path visiting every node in
the graph exactly once.
And Hamilton started to actually introduce
this problem by trying to solve the puzzles
that I showed here, how to visit every node
in this graph [INAUDIBLE].
Now, a human genome indeed was assembled using
essentially a solution of the Hamiltonian
path problem, [? algorithm, ?] a sophisticated
algorithm for solving problems that are similar
to Hamiltonian Path Problem.
But when short [? maturation ?] sequencing
merge, people switch from this computational
technology to something else, to a completely
new idea.
So let me describe how most genomes are assembled
today, and it uses different approach.
So this is my Hamiltonian-- solution of Hamiltonian
Path Problem for this [? graph.
?] But it is not the only solution.
This is another solution.
And of course, in the graph of [INAUDIBLE]
is pointing to real genome sequencing problem.
There will be billions of [INAUDIBLE].
So what can we do?
Let's describe a slightly different approach
for constructing the [? grounds ?] of [INAUDIBLE]
assembly problem.
Remember, this is our old graph.
And in this case, our k-mers represent nodes.
I now want k-mers to represent edges rather
than noes.
That seems like a strange desire and almost
like cosmetic modification [? or ?] for what
we are doing.
Wait a little bit, and you will see that this
is actually the [INAUDIBLE] ideas that completely
turns the table in this game.
So they represent not-- [? notice ?] the difference
between previous [? pictures ?] of [INAUDIBLE]
that we analyze and the new [? picture.
?] Now, edges [INAUDIBLE].
But how do we label starting connecting nodes
of every edge?
Well, of course, we should label the starting
node by a prefix of a k-mer and an ending
node by a suffix of k-mer.
So that will look like this, OK?
And that represents now-- this picture represents
my genome.
And now I will do something that is completely,
extremely strange.
I will ask you to do the following.
Think about this path as a threat, and start
gluing nodes with these identical labels.
For example, AT appears three times in my
genomic path.
I will glue them together, like I show here,
and they will get closer together and finally
glued into a single node.
Instead of three nodes AT, I will have one
node AT.
Now, I will continue doing this.
I see three nodes TG in my graph.
Once again, I will bring them together and
glue them in a single node.
I [INAUDIBLE] not yet, because there is also
two nodes [? GG.
?] I will bring them closer together, and
that's what I've got.
And where is the genome hiding in this graph?
Well, we were simply just gluing nodes, so
the genome is just [? passed ?] in this graph,
[INAUDIBLE] all edges, right?
So this is my genome.
And a path, that means that each edge was
a graph exactly once.
It's called an Eulerian path.
Please note the difference.
In Hamiltonian paths, we are talking about
paths that visit every nod exactly
once.
Now we are talking about paths that visit
every edge exactly once.
Again, it seems like a semantic difference.
So we have [? now a two ?] problem-- Eulerian
Path Problem.
Find the path [INAUDIBLE] the graph exactly
once; 300 years old.
And it started by Leonhard Euler, the great
mathematician, one of the greatest mathematicians
of all time, who asked a question.
Can he walk through the city of [INAUDIBLE],
which had seven bridges, in such a way that
you can visit every bridge exactly once and
return back home?
And if you look at this city and try to do
this, you will [INAUDIBLE] see is that it
is not possible.
This problem was so influential for general
assemblies, that there is even a company called
Seven Bridges, named Seven Bridges, to recognize
the contribution on this old puzzle to genome
assembly.
Now, if you look at this problem, it's even
difficult to find a difference.
There is only one difference here, difference
between node and edge.
Well, why did I spend so much time trying
to present to you two semantically [? near
?] identical problem?
Allow me to explain.
So we have two problems now.
And so these two problem correspond to these
two graphs.
Well, which graph would you prefer?
Well, in the first graph, you would prefer
to [INAUDIBLE] graph on the right, because
it is smaller.
But that would be a wrong [INAUDIBLE], because
each of these graphs will have millions of
that as a [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe one, you'll have two million, and other,
you'll have one million.
It doesn't matter.
They all will be gigantic.
So unless you know how to solve this problem,
how to travel in this gigantic graph, you
are going to fail.
The key reason why I introduce these two seemingly,
very similar problem is because, while Euler
solves the Euler impasse problem, even for
a city with a billion bridges, he suggested
the genius algorithm that will solve this
problem for whatever size of the graph.
Nobody has developed a fast algorithm for
the Hamiltonian Path Problem even for a city
of just 1,000 [? nodes.
?] So two algorithmic problems may look nearly
identical, but they may be dramatically different
with respect to tractability, or whether it's
possible to develop an algorithm for solving
this problem.
And it turn outs that Hamiltonian Path Problem
belongs to a collection containing 1,000s
of computational problems for which generations
of computer scientists failed to solve.
And for sometimes, they have a guilt [INAUDIBLE],
because they though maybe they're stupid,
and they can solve.
And then there isn't [INAUDIBLE] who couldn't
solve it.
But then the situation has changed.
They started to think that they cannot solve
it, maybe, just maybe, because nobody can
solve it, because they're intractable in principle.
That would be an excellent argument to demonstrate
to your boss you cannot solve this problem,
because nobody can solve it, because it isn't
[? tractable.
?] But the [?
time ?] to do this are very complex.
It's actually one of the so-called Millennium
million dollar prize problem, to prove the
Hamiltonian Path Problem isn't [? tractable.
?]
And that's why computer scientists develop
a theory called NP-Completeness theory.
And now the argument to your boss has changed.
They proved that all these problems, that
1,000s of problems that Hamiltonian Path Problem
belong to, I actually [? agree ?] with it.
And since each of these problem, for each
these problem, there very smart people that
were trying to solve it.
The argument now, I can't find an efficient
algorithm, but all these geniuses standing
in line also can't find this efficient algorithm.
And [INAUDIBLE] you probably heard sometime.
Bioinfomatician [? Torbes ?] uses this term
NPCompleteness to refer to the problems that
is hopeless.
But in our case, it looks like we should follow
the Euler path and [INAUDIBLE] de Bruijn,
because Euler proposed an efficient algorithm
for solving the problem.
However, I don't know if you noticed, but
I cheated in my talk.
We constructed the de Bruijn graph from [? genome.
?] But reality, the genome is unknown.
So here, Euler can't solve Euler [INAUDIBLE]
path problem in this graph.
But to construct this graph, you only have
reads.
You don't have the genome.
It's defined as the goal.
So what we've done, from genome, we know how
to construct the graph.
And from graph, we know how to find a genome
in this graph, using [INAUDIBLE].
But what we really have, we have reads only.
And our goal is to construct the genome.
We now achieve this goal in two steps.
First, we will construct the de Bruijn graph
from reads, and then we apply our Euler [? algorithm
?] to find the genome in this graph.
Make sense?
So let's see how it's done.
It's actually very easy.
So now we don't have the genome.
We only have reads.
But let's do something [? with this algorithm
?] reads, and let's represent every read as
a single edge between two nodes.
With each nodes, the first node will be the
suffix of the three.
Then the second will be-- sorry, the first
node will be the prefix of this read, and
the second node will be the suffix of this.
And then afterwards, let's do exactly what
we did before.
Let's glue nodes with these identical labels.
So here, we glue this.
Glue, continue gluing.
And look.
We are in the same position we had before.
All these reads magically glued in the genome
path.
Bat that, of course, also is cheating, because
I haven't finished my gluing.
I should continue gluing before.
And after I completed this, I got exactly
the same graph from reads that I would get
from the genome.
We don't know the genome yet.
But de Bruijn graph of genome is exactly the
same as de Bruijn graph of reads.
And this is fundamental observation [INAUDIBLE]
your behind modern assembly algorithm.
So one more time, to define de Bruijn graph
of a collection of k-mers, for you, a collection
of k-mers is, of course,
a collection of, let's say, 100 nucleotide
or 200 nucleotide on one [? grid.
?] Represent every k-mer as an edge between
its prefix and suffix.
And then glue all nodes with identical labels.
That sounds almost trivial, but that's how
great ideas all often are.
After you distilled everything, they appear
amazingly elegant and simple.
So you may be wondering, why Hamilton, Euler,
and de Bruijn thought about this problem.
They didn't think about this problem.
De Bruijn, in fact, thought about a different,
purely mathematical puzzle.
He wanted to find a circular string containing
each binary k-mer exactly once.
So here, all binary k-mer, all strings, in
the alphabet of 0s and 1s, and de Bruijn wanted
to construct a circular string that contains
each of these k-mer exactly once.
At that time, when he asked this question,
it wasn't even clear whether it's possible
or not.
And it's, of course, not obvious.
If you do it for k-mer, let's say, not for
the small k-mer, when we can explore it by
hand, but for a k-mer of reasonable size,
let's say, of size 100.
So once again, in this circular string, each
of these eight [? 3-mers ?] on the top appears
once.
And how is this problem is relevant to genome
assembly?
Well, the only thing we want to do is to assemble
these [? 3-mers ?] into genome, like into
[INAUDIBLE] genome.
And what we you, we represent each [INAUDIBLE]
as a match between two nodes and then simply
glue elements, nodes, with these identical
labels.
And we have this graph.
So this is de Bruijn graph for boolean string.
And then we need simply to travel in this
graph to find the solution of our problem.
Now, in our case, for a very simple graph,
the solution is clear.
But how would you find the solution in the
de Bruijn graph of reads containing millions
of nodes?
And here, it brings us to the next point that
I was fascinated, whether I should present
it or not.
But then finally, I decided I should present
it, and I should take you through the torture
of proving [? theorems.
?] Because if I give you a talk on algorithm
and optimization in data science, without
giving you an example of how theorems are
proved, I will be chicken.
Because the hard work of computer scientists
also includes proving [? theorem.
?]
So please bear with me.
I will try to make this proof very simple
and even entertaining.
And in the end, you can ask questions.
Anyway, let's go back to finding-- to solving
the problem of finding an Eulerian cycle.
And so we want, given the graph, we want to
find the cycle that visits every edge of the
graph exactly once.
I have to ask you some question.
Is this graph Eulerian?
Does it have a cycle visiting ever edge exactly
once?
Of course not, because the right [INAUDIBLE]
is a dead end, right?
What about this graph?
It's also not Eulerian, because there is no
even way to visit the right vertex.
There are no edges entering.
And how about this graph?
This is a little bit more complex.
But if you look at this vertex, there is one
edge entering this vertex and two edges getting
out of this vertex.
Therefore, there is no Eulerian path visiting
all edges in this graph, because if you enter
into a node, you have to leave it, right?
So to leave it two times, you have to enter
at least two times also.
So those are examples of normal Eulerian graph.
And it also illustrate that every Eulerian
graph should be balanced, which means the
number of incoming edges in every node equals
the number of outcoming edges for every node.
And if you look at this graph, [? they're
?] different constructed, it actually satisfies
these conditions.
There are two nodes, two edges entering every
node, and two edges leaving every node.
So we just proved that every Eulerian graph
is balanced.
But it doesn't tell us yet whether every balanced
graph is Eulerian.
OK?
And that's what we are going to prove, that
if a graph is balanced, which means, in every
node, there is the same number of entering
edges as the number of outgoing edges.
Then we can construct an Eulerian cycle.
Let's do this.
It will take me just three minutes.
So to do this, we need to recruit an ant.
And we let ant randomly walk through the graph.
And of course, since we need to visit every
edge exactly once, the ant cannot use the
same edge twice.
Now, if ant was a genius, that ant would start
working and simply magically would pass through
all edges of the graph and solve the problem.
But a less intelligent ant would go and would
start working, and probably would start somewhere.
So the ant walk randomly.
And in this case, it actually stuck in the
node.
There is no egress out of this node, and the
ant has not completed that Eulerian walk yet.
Well, what should we do?
His idea is that Euler came [INAUDIBLE].
You know what?
Ant actually did a good job.
He just started at the wrong node.
Maybe we can ask ant to start at a different
node.
Well, what node would it be?
Well, if you look at this green cycle, there
are some nodes on this green cycle [? at this
?] still unexplored address.
And why shouldn't we do this?
Or why shouldn't we start at the node to these
unexplored edges and still continue walking
along the green cycle, but starting from this
node.
The point is that, when we return back, there
will be an edge to continue our walk.
Let's do this.
This is first edge, second, third, fourth.
But now there is a possibility to move further,
right?
We move further, move further, move further,
move further.
And we're stuck again.
Well, what should we do?
Well, now you've probably figured out that
we need to continue walking along this cycle
that ant just completed, but starting from
a different node.
Well, what node should we select?
Once again, node will be a still unexplored
address, or which will be this node.
So what do you do?
We once again, we utilize the previous job
that the ant did and walk along the previous
cycle.
So that's what we do.
Now we return back to the right node.
But we can't continue walking.
So ant continue walking, continue walking,
continue walking.
And finally, ant completed the Eulerian cycle.
The beauty of this proof is that it immediately
implies a very efficient algorithm for solving
the Eulerian cycle problem, because what I
just described
was very essentially algorithmic instruction
to the ant or to your computer on how to find
such cycles.
And the algorithm is very efficient.
Now, when you formulate and when you [? broke
?] collaboratively, you [? lose ?] your computational
[INAUDIBLE] a good program for them.
But it's also very important that your problems
adequately model reality.
So problems that I describe doesn't model
reality of assembly.
And that's why there are 1,000s of papers
on this topic, and many, many groups working
on this still up to this day.
So in [INAUDIBLE], they made sound ridiculously
unrealistic assumption.
For example, they assume that there is perfect
coverage of genome by reads, which means every
k-mer from the genome is represented by reads.
This is wrong, of course, in real biological
problem.
They assume that reads are error-free, which
is wrong.
They assume that multiplicities of k-mers
are known.
Many, many wrong assumptions are made here.
In fact, in reality, we have imperfect coverage.
Reads are errorprone.
Multiplicities of k-mers are unknown.
And computer scientists and algorithmists
know how to deal with this assumption.
Also, of course, modern [? assemblers ?] is
one of the most sophisticated pieces of hardware
today-- of software in modern biology.
And for example, in the case of imperfect
read coverage, their assumption [? is ?] counter-intuitive.
They do.
They actually break every reads into shorter
k-mers to do assembly.
For example, if you generated 250-nucleotide
[INAUDIBLE] reads, computer scientists will
most likely break them into, let's say, 55-nucleotide
reads to ensure better coverage by short k-mers.
Another things, what do they do with errors
in reads?
Well, in this case, if you have erroneous
reads, then your perfect genomic path that
you [? go ?] looking at will be complemented
by a bubble.
Every error creates a bubble in the graph
that is incorrect.
So when you look at the genome, then in addition
to correct passes in this graph, correspondence
of genome, there are many, many enormous number
of bottles, maybe billions of bottles.
And your goal is to figure out how to remove
them and how to find the correct path.
If I drew this graph definitely, you would
not know where correct path is, because I
would drew it through the bubbles.
So this is another problem computer scientists
are trying to solve.
And of course, I cannot cover this into the
reasons at time of this talk.
But let me give you an idea.
So this is a de Bruijn graph of bacterial
genome after all these problems were addressed.
And I can tell you that, at [INAUDIBLE] the
de Bruijn graph [INAUDIBLE] removes all bubbles,
would consist of probably 20 or 30 million
address.
So you can appreciate the complexity of this
problem.
Now, I use this example as just one section
of our course on Bioinformatics Specialization
on Coursera.
And the
textbook that we use for this course, that
is freely available as a part of our content
delivery system.
And we covered only one of the algorithmic
topics that we discussed in this course.
[INAUDIBLE] and we connect various biological
problem with specific algorithmic challenges.
For example, biologists do not realize that
algorithmists often toss coin and trust to
random chance to solve their problem.
For example, [INAUDIBLE] finding are heavily
based on so-called randomized [? algo rate,
?] when we toss a coin.
And here, you can see an artist [? draw ?] me
and my colleague Philip Compeau trying to
toss a coin on the table where there's some
biological quantums there.
We currently discussed only one section--
assembly, the [? site of ?] which is based
on graph [? algorithms.
?] Those will just cause brute force [? algorithms.
?] There's another big area of [? algorithms
?] when big data, and discuss how they apply
to sequencing antibiotics.
Of course, we discuss the extremely important
area of modern computer science, dynamic programming.
And this is the work horse behind your sequence
comparison [? algorithm.
?]
We discussed combinatorial algorithms as a
small course, for example, for study rearrangements
in the human genome.
We discuss evolutionary construction, using
the story of source outbreak as an example.
We ask a question, how it is become a [INAUDIBLE]
as a reason to discuss [? class rank ?] algorithm,
another huge part of big data analysis that
is applied to many problems in biology.
We, of course, in this course discuss how
biologists find [INAUDIBLE] And it brings
in another huge area in algorithmic science,
which is called combinatorial [? automation.
?] We also discuss the question of why have
biologists still not developed an HIV vaccine,
and describe a link to very important work
horse of [INAUDIBLE] in big data, which is
called hidden marker models, or HMM.
We also discuss a question, was T Rex just
a big chicken?
And this is another area of computational
approach [INAUDIBLE] that we discuss in the
course.
So I want just to illustrate that I covered
extremely small fragment of algorithmic [? status
?] in big data, and it's a big area.
And I think my talk is coming to the end.
But I still have time to send my partner in
crime, Phillip Compeau, Professor-- my former
student, who is now a professor at Carnegie
Mellon University.
That project would not be possible without
NIH [? R2 ?] BD2K Program.
And I'm also very grateful to HHMI for the
Professor Award, that also contributed to
these studies.
And of course, we are extremely grateful to
1,000s and 1,000s of our Coursera students,
who provided invaluable feedback and continue
providing it.
So our course is not static.
It's an adaptive course in the sense that
we constantly update it, based on feedback
from our students.
And we are also very extremely fortunate to
have a [? following of ?] over 50 professor
at various university who adopted our content
and essentially teach the same story I just
told you in one of their classes, and use
our
textbook for their classes.
So we are very pleased that this work that
was supported by NIH, HHMI, was taken very
positively by so many professors worldwide.
And I think I finished on time.
Thank you.
Pavel, thank you so much for a fantastic talk--
entertaining and funny.
And I know ants are known for working hard.
But they work particularly hard in your presentation
there.
So thank you so much for that.
And I want to encourage our folks who are
out there online to send in any questions
that you may have for Dr. Pevzner via our
question submission system, that's part of
the go to webinar system.
Send those in, and then I will pick and choose
and read them off Pavel, and he can spend
some time addressing them.
So while people are thinking about those questions,
one of the things which seemed to be pretty
obvious to me is that this pattern of matching
and marrying and merging different nodes and
different models, it seems like it would have
applications across a wide variety of biological
problems, I mean, in particular, like complex
biochemical pathways, I mean, things, I mean
imagining them-- like the Krebs cycle here
as just one very fundamental approach.
Have you tried to do any of that in your courses
or in any other of your research in looking
at complex biomedical pathways and how you
might decide whether or not they're Eulerian
or Hamiltonian, et cetera?
You're absolutely right.
De Bruijn graph originally was proposed for
assembly.
But since that time here, it has become the
work horse in many different areas of bioinformatic.
For example, antibody sequencing today, protein
sequencing based on mass spectometry data,
is done based on de Bruijn graph.
Analysis of immune sequencing data is also
done based on de Bruijn graph.
Analysis of [INAUDIBLE] is done based on de
Bruijn graph.
And there are many, many other applications.
And some of you may know that-- because this
concept of [? colored ?] de Bruijn graph for
representing human population genomes.
So there are many application, and there is
[INAUDIBLE].
Right.
[INAUDIBLE]
Go ahead.
Yeah, go ahead.
No, I was just going to follow up on that.
It's really interesting, the potential applications.
I was thinking about many of the instances,
where they're all discrete things, right?
Every node is kind of its own discrete thing,
and the paths are basically, there is a path
between one node and another.
And you can create these graphs.
What happens if some of those edges in these
graphs, what happens if they have a weight
attached to them?
So I guess, for example, if you're thinking
about the seven bridges problem, what if one
of those bridges is like a drawbridge.
Or rather, one of them is a narrower bridge.
Maybe it's a one-lane bridge.
Or maybe another bridge is not a bridge at
all, but its a zipline.
And so you could get across really fast, but
you can only grab one person at a time.
How did those kind of concepts get factored
into some of this modeling?
So these concepts are very important, because
when you construct de Bruijn graph for assembly,
all-- I didn't mention it, but all-- [? address
?] have weights.
And these weights represent coverage of the
corresponding k-mer in the genome-
I see.
[INAUDIBLE] if it isn't myriads.
And then assembly [? algorithms ?] that are
working [INAUDIBLE] take into account and
work harder with these coverages, because
that's a way for them to distinguish bulges
from real edges.
And so there's this [INAUDIBLE] in that all
real applications, [? address ?] are weighted.
Right.
Well, so one of our listeners asked, are we
guaranteed a single Euler path for any given
graph?
Or do sometimes we arrive at more than one
possible candidate?
Well, in the case of [INAUDIBLE] a short [? rate.
?] It's [? almost always, ?] even for a bacterial
genomes, there are multiplied passes.
And as a result, biologists, in such cases,
use [INAUDIBLE] rather than various passes,
because if there are so many passes, it's
not clear how to represent them.
However, [INAUDIBLE] technology specific bioscience
[INAUDIBLE] the graphs become much nicer.
And for many of them, there is one Eulerian
cycle.
For example, for bacterial genomes, [? assemble
?] these obvious specific biosciences, I said,
in 80%, 90% of cases, we actually have a single
cycle, which makes it very nice.
One of our other listeners is asking, in some
of your own modeling, are you picking off
the data from an individual genome, for, say,
somebody that's like my genome?
Or would you say try to fit these algorithms
to reference algorithms?
And then somebody else asked, is there-- basically
they're implying-- is there any way to do
this across people and then use all of these
graphs to match the graphs across people,
to identify cohorts or people with similar
genomic segments or sections, if you will?
So until recently, it was pretty difficult,
based on short periods, to accurately assemble
human genome.
But I believe that [? obvious, ?] long [? grids
?] and more accurate assemblies, they indeed
have a huge number of accurately assembled
human genomes.
And the will have no choice but to represent
them in the structure similar to de Bruijn
graphs.
And also, there is a question on are these
possible for use in applications in structural
biology?
And could you apply them in three or maybe
more dimensions, if necessary?
That's an interesting question.
I actually do not know.
It is not my research area.
But it would be very interesting to see it.
Whether it is possible, I can tell you that
new applications are happening as we speak.
There are more and more applications of this
concept people find.
But I did not see applications in 3D biology
yet.
Right.
And then do you find these are-- I mean, it
looks like you've got-- some of your course
material has been adopted at 50 universities,
and counting within the last couple of years.
And do you find that these methodologies,
these are catching on, and people-- this is
starting to find purchase in how people do
genomic sequencing, using the latest, greatest
state-of-the-art techniques?
While the courses are mainly for students,
and they are still finishing their studies,
but these ideas that I describe, they are
definitely behind the dominant assembly tools.
So they are already-- they've been there for
the last 10 years.
And as I mentioned, so this human genome was
assembled, using [INAUDIBLE] technology, which
was quite a feat, an enormous, enormous achievement.
But in the last 10 years, people are mainly
using the outlines that I describe.
How do the companies like the Seven Bridges
people-- how do they do things that's maybe
different than what you've illustrated here?
Well, Seven Bridges has, I believe, a lot
of research programs that is not necessarily
limited to assembly only.
Maybe it was something in the beginning [INAUDIBLE],
but they have now a genome, large, rather
large bioinformatics company.
So most of [INAUDIBLE] in their assembly is
concentrated in places like MIT, Beijing Genome
Institute, in British Columbia, Genome Center,
and other places, and my own lab.
So I would say most of efforts in this are
actually happening in academia, rather than
in company.
Interesting.
Has anybody who's working in the field, have
they attempted to play with algorithms which
start with longer k-mers, to minimize possibly
the number of edges and nodes, and then simplify
things, and try to resolve things that were
not possible under the smaller size?
Does that make sense?
Yes.
People definitely want to play with longer
k-mer.
In fact, the [INAUDIBLE] people at University
of Hong Kong, who develop [? IDBA, ?] popular
[? IDBA ?] Assembler, [INAUDIBLE] first realize
how to incorporate longer and longer k-mers
in the de Bruijn graph.
And they developed the concept of iterative
assembly, [? where ?] when kmer lens is not
fixed, like in the setups that I presented,
but is [? changing.
?] So and that allows them to incorporate
longer k-mers in the framework.
Well, one last question is I wasn't quite
clear on how you identified the bubbles that
you mentioned in some of your de Bruijn graphs.
I'm sure that that's kind of a laborious process,
to identify them, and probably an even
more laborious process to decide which ones
are real and which ones are, in fact, bubbles
and can be popped, if you will.
Just a little summary of how that process
happens and how long it takes?
So bubble are simply represented as a short
cycle in the graph, right?
So that's how it looks like.
Because every error in a read creates relatively
a short-- they create basically alternative
paths between two nodes.
Now, finding them is not a problem.
It's actually difficult not to notice them,
because there are so many them.
Every read usually has an error.
So imagine you have millions of reads mean
millions [? of model.
?] The question is, how to efficiently get
rid of them and how to remove them from the
graph without destroying the correct errors.
That would take me another hour to cover.
[LAUGHS] Well, maybe we'll have to find another
hour for you to explain that process.
It sounds like that's pretty laborious.
But at any rate.
Well, listen, everyone, we've reached the
top of the hour here.
I want to thank Professor Pevzner from UC,
San Diego, for a really interesting and entertaining
talk on algorithms optimization and graph
theory and bridges and ants.
And everything that he covered is really,
truly a remarkable presentation.
I think it just fit perfectly into our goals
here through our Big Data to Knowledge Guide
[? and ?] the Fundamentals of Data Science.
I want to thank you all for joining us today.
And thank you again to Dr. Pevzner.
And everyone, have a great weekend.
And we'll look forward to seeing you next
week.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.